[Aplausos]
vamos a ponernos todos al mismo nivel
para aprender algunas diferencias y
poder entender mejor esta charla
ahora levanten la mano quienes creen que
él es un hacker
levanten la mano nuevamente quienes
creen que ellos son hackers
bueno todos los que levantaron la mano
están equivocados
el primero es un cibercriminal que usa
sus altos conocimientos en técnicas
hacking para entrar ilegalmente más
sistemas y robar información
y estos son activistas de anónimos que
luchan por sus objetivos
ellos son especialistas de seguridad
informática nosotros sí somos hackers
pero qué es un hacker
según el internet engineering task force
que es la organización internacional que
regula los estándares en internet un
hacker es una persona con un íntimo
conocimiento en el funcionamiento un
sistema computadoras y específicamente
redes de computadoras
pero a menudo este término ha sido mal
utilizado en un contexto peyorativo
donde cracker es el término correcto
necesitamos preocuparnos mucho más por
nuestra propia seguridad y por eso ahora
les pregunto
quienes de ustedes tienen encendido el
wifi en sus teléfonos en este momento
comprarlo
perfecto hoy sigan
bueno pues saben que al tenerlo
encendido el wifi sus teléfonos están
preguntándoles a otros dispositivos si
la redes wifi a las cuales se han
conectado están disponibles
con dispositivos como este se pueden
capturar estas redes wifi e interceptar
su información peligroso
es por eso que ahora les recomiendo
apaguen la señal wifi de su teléfono
cada vez que salgan de sus casas
veamos ahora un poco sobre un tipo de
ataque muy usado por ciberdelincuentes y
es el phising este consiste en que un
ciberdelincuente le envía un correo a
una víctima ya sea con una actualización
o con un inicio de sesión sospechoso y
un enlace para que la víctima puede
ingresar sus usuarios o contraseña y así
regalar su cuenta el fihsin es uno de
los ataques más utilizados en los
sistemas bancarios para poder
comprometer tanto al empleado al sistema
bancario pero principalmente ustedes
como usuarios con sus tarjetas las
cuales estos números terminan siendo
comercializados nadar web
pero como me puedo proteger del phising
bueno lo primero es que nunca ningún
proveedor de correo electrónico ni de
sus redes sociales y mucho menos de su
banco les va a enviar un correo
electrónico para que ustedes ingresen
sus usuarios su contraseña
tengan mucho cuidado en las páginas
donde ingresan sus usuarios y sus
contraseñas principalmente como lo
pueden ver con los errores ortográficos
que es muy común en las páginas
confusión y por último y es fundamental
que activen el segundo factor de
autenticación con la autenticación de
dos pasos
vamos a hablar un poco de nuestra propia
seguridad pero a nivel bancario
ahora dígame quién es de ustedes reciben
un mensaje de texto
como segundo factor de autenticación
cada vez que ingresan a su banca en
línea personal
muy pocos
ahora quién es de ustedes reciben un
mensaje de texto para probar una
transacción
a muchos
pero ahora cuántos de ustedes ingresan
el pin de su cuenta en un post en el
salvador para probar una transacción
ninguno
en la india y en otros países es
obligatorio
que estas medidas de seguridad sean
necesarias
obviamente obligatorias por los sistemas
bancarios y de comercio electrónico
pero la pregunta es por qué la india y
otros países y no el salvador
porque la india y otros países sí tienen
hackers los cuales pueden mejorar estas
medidas de seguridad e implementarlas y
en el salvador no nos permiten
es por esto que urgen hackers
es por esto que urgen hackers que puedan
ayudar técnicamente en los estudios de
las leyes financieras del comercio
electrónico y de protección de datos
personales
ahora veamos un poco de riesgo
sólo el 13 por ciento de las empresas
salvadoreñas en el 2017 lograron
reportar malware
esto significa que el 87 por ciento
restante no logro reportar ningún tipo
de malware
porque esto puede ver puede deberse
tanto a falta de políticas de seguridad
miedo al riesgo reputacional falta de
tecnología necesaria pero lo principal a
falta de hackers que puedan detectar a
tiempo estas amenazas es por esto que
urgen hackers
el 61 por ciento de las empresas en
latinoamérica
reportaron al menos un incidente de
seguridad y estoy incluido el ram
software pero que es el malware
es un código malicioso el cual puede ir
adentro de un programa enlaces o
imágenes con la finalidad de acceder a
través del correo electrónico o usb
desconocidas para permanecer oculto en
un sistema captura la información y
enviarla a buen atacante
pero también que es el ransomware
es un tipo de malware el cual cifra la
información
tiene un sistema operativo capturando
los secuestrándola y pidiendo un rescate
para poder recuperarlo
en el 2017 se dio un incidente uno de
los más fuertes registrados y fue con el
ransomware wanna write el cual afectó
aproximadamente 230 mil computadoras en
150 países o más y fue un especialista
de seguridad o hacker llamado marcos
hosting al es baluarte quien pudo parar
este ransomware registrando con el
nombre de dominio encontrado el código
en mi experiencia
como consultor de seguridad he logrado
encontrar varias fallas de seguridad
de las cuales les puedo mencionar dos
una de estas fallas fue
al exceder al accesar perdón a un
sistema
de contribuyentes
pude filtrar tanto usuarios como
contraseñas
pero no a cualquier usuario
números de nit y contraseñas
se imaginan ustedes a un
ciberdelincuente
que tenga sus números de nit y sus
contraseñas para poder entrar en sus
cuentas y mientras ustedes no se den
cuenta llevarse todo su dinero
pues este reporte esto lo reporte e
inmediatamente se solventó para mejorar
su seguridad en sus datos digitales con
contribuyentes
el segundo caso según un ejemplo de
igual manera fue
con un error de seguridad muy similar a
la anterior en el cual también logré
filtrar usuarios y contraseñas para
poder acceder a un sistema financiero
de la misma manera este error lo pude
reportar y se solventó inmediatamente no
asegurando la información
pero porque en el salvador tenemos tan
pocos hackers que podemos encontrar este
tipo de vulnerabilidades
para poderlas solventar y mejorar toda
la seguridad del salvador
es por esto que urgen hackers y ahora
vamos a ver
hoy
un último dato nada más
en el salvador o el salvador está en el
puesto 142 de 175 países en el ranking
global de ciberseguridad
y esto qué significa
que estamos haciendo las cosas muy mal
en este tema y que necesitamos y urgen
hackers ahora vamos a ver como un
ciberdelincuente puede acceder a una
computadora
así que vamos a tratar de explotar un
sistema
pero también les quiero pedir un favor
quiero que cuenten cuántas palabras me
toma tratar de explorar este sistema y
cuánto tiempo me puede tomar hacerlo así
que lo primero que vamos a hacer primero
que haré
es tomar y configurar este exploit vamos
a configurar primero
la ip de la máquina cual voy a atacar
así que ya tengo lo primero así que
ahora voy a configurar un payload el
cual
es muy conocido y es un código malicioso
con el cual voy a tener muchas opciones
adentro de esta computadora este pelo se
llama meter preter así que lo va a
terminar de configurar
y ahora voy a configurar la ip de la
máquina a la cual desde la cual voy a
atacar en este caso va a configurar la
que es la ip 135
y ahora voy a lanzar este exploit voy a
lanzar este ataque a esta computadora
este exploit es muy pero muy reciente
se llama block y espero que funcione
también esta es una prueba en vivo y por
lo residente tiende a fallado y debo
decirle que esté floyd ataca vulnera el
servicio de escritorio remoto y
actualmente también este tipo de exploit
está afectando aproximadamente a un
millón de computadoras y como ven ya
logramos acceso
como un ciberdelincuente que puedo tener
acceso que puedo hacer podemos ver
nuestros privilegios y con eso podemos
hacer es ver qué tipo de usuarios somos
y vemos que somos un usuario
administrador pero qué más podemos hacer
bueno pues también
podemos investigar qué tipo
de archivos maliciosos o qué tipo de
archivos tiene esta computadora además
de esto
podríamos ver y extraer credenciales o
usuarios y contraseñas y esto de sistema
nada más pero de qué sirve solamente
usuarios y contraseñas
qué pasaría es un ciberdelincuente usa o
puede extraer usuarios y contraseñas de
bases de datos y de bases de datos no
solo de archivos confidenciales no solo
bases de datos confidenciales sino que
de bases de datos financieras
pues puede también
pues podría también acceder a mucha
información bancaria ahora como ya
tenemos
la información
sobre
el administrador también podríamos hacer
algo muy pero muy interesante y al cual
es
podríamos tratar de acceder en este caso
en forma remota al administrador
configuramos nada más ahora la ip
el ataque de la máquina a la cual estoy
atacando y
configuramos la eep en sololá vamos a
confirmar o si ésta
perdón
como éxito
y como vemos ya entramos en esta
computadora
ahora les pregunto cuánto tiempo me tomo
entre en este sistema y con cuántas
palabras
y para un ciberdelincuente que tiene
todo el límite que no tiene límite
realmente el tiempo y tampoco no tiene
límite en recursos cuánto tiempo le va a
tomar hacer esto
es por esto que urgen hackers
es por esto que somos tan importantes
porque nosotros podemos detectar todas
estas vulnerabilidades y mucho más antes
que un ciberdelincuente lo haga
muchas gracias en este plan
[Aplausos]